we're now almost a week into April so
I'm a little bit behind in shooting this
update video in which i'm going to talk
about what went on in march and what
we've got coming up in April March was
extraordinarily busy lots of work lots
of great projects April is shaping up to
be like that as well although there's
not quite so many events on the calendar
there's a lot of behind-the-scenes work
so i'll talk about that once we get to
that that portion i always like to
highlight three big things before i go
into the discussion of each month and so
this month the first of the big things
is that we've got an Aristotle
Nicomachean ethics class six weeks
online class coming up starting May
first but all of the back and work and
the enrollment and advertising and even
an open house that will talk about is
going to happen in April so that's one
thing the second is that we have I think
effectively crossed a milestone in the
half hour Hagel series not having to do
with the content but having to do with
the Patrian contributions that people
are making I've said it so once we reach
certain levels there's things that I've
committed to do that that kick in and
one of them I think everybody's going to
be happy to hear about this is to get
our hands on some new equipment so we'll
talk about that a bit more and the third
thing the the big talk that I've got
coming up this month which is actually
happening next week is on CS lewis and
i'm not talking about narnia i'm talking
about the space trilogy that he wrote
with perelandra and out of the hideous
planet those are actually an order and
that hideous strength which is is the
last book wonderful stuff and I'll talk
about that a little bit more in the
April section so let's talk about the
month of March as I said it was
extraordinarily busy in part because if
you if you look at my reason I oh
calendar which you can find on the
reason I all site you see all of the
speaking engage
means that I had also you know I did
videos for each other as well so if you
missed them you can you can watch them
we began the month with a talk on 8 on
the science fiction author AE van Voight
really favorite author of mine and his
world of null a then towards the middle
of the month i gave a talk for women's
history month at the Shorewood public
library on mary wollstonecraft as a
philosophical exemplar i gave another
truck not too long after that called who
were the existentialist sand and what
was it all about at that the Wauwatosa
public library and I finished up the
month by flying out to Virginia for an
invited lecture at Virginia Commonwealth
University on among other things what
can analytic and continental
philosophers learn from each other i did
manage to smuggle in some other topics
as well we had a half-hour Hagel public
QA as we do every month so that was
another event and although i think if i
remember right we shot the video the
month before the the interview that I
did with marcus mig tau that came out in
in in March as well and that took you
know quite a bit of planning and work it
was a good month as far as my some of my
other activities go did quite a bit of
tutoring that I always enjoy that some
philosophical counseling I you know I
enjoyed that as well flying philosophy
in very practical ways to individual
clients and I I also did some some work
with with coaching with other clients
another big bit of news for marched I
think that also made it very busy
although that you know we prepared for
this was that I officially took over as
the editor of the stoicism today blog
which is a kind of a big thing it meant
becoming part you know an official
member of the stoicism today project
which is a great honor very happy about
that it means i'll be speaking at stella
Khan this this fall in New York the huge
you know conference that we have will be
giving a workshop actually i'll tell you
more about that later but you know it
means i'm also writing pieces for the
blog and editing other people's I'm
fielding inquiries you know it's being a
nexus fortunately the guy who was the
editor before me Patrick usher left it
in incredibly good condition and Tom
McConnell the assistant he is a real
godsend so that you know it makes it
much easier to to do I also did some
writing in my own blogs I made the
decision to close down two of my blogs
virtue ethics digest and samplers
existentialism updates I'm not going to
be contributing to them anymore but I
did write some entries in her exes do
know NTK which was the first blog I ever
started and i'm going to be you know
doing maybe four or five entries and
that a month maybe more if i get
ambitious and got to do some more
writing for the half hour Hagel blog i
get to put myself on the line for some
articles on Hagel and and stoicism but i
got the first one written so that's
that's good more later this week
hopefully what else i released some some
additional courses on the curious
learning platform that's that's a puts
links to that below if you're interested
in that sort of thing that's sort of
like youtube except there's a bit more
interactivity and that there's exercises
built in and handouts and links and you
know cool stuff like that did some i
actually got some academic writing done
for once i mostly dealing with with
anger not not on everything that i
wanted to work on but with some things
got some works work done on editing
articles that i need to send out and i
did some work in course building for
like I said the Aristotle course it's
coming up but I've got some other cool
things in the works for that as as well
now video work I got back up to shooting
six half hour Hagel videos as I've
committed to do in the past and not
always been able to do but I got
done this months are very happy about
their did videos of all for talks that I
gave three of them locally one in
Virginia and we finally finished up with
releasing those you know I don't know
how many 50 odd videos on Epictetus and
his discourses that I had created in the
fall and I got to start releasing videos
on core concept videos on an Psalms
manalo June thinker who I've been
working on for boy least you know in a
professional way at least 15 years maybe
more now probably about 15 years I've
been publishing and writing on him and
presenting and I was high time I started
shooting some videos about the guy so
that was the month of March pretty
packed so let's talk now about what
we've got coming up in a month of April
at least at this point I'm not releasing
the video after any of these things that
happened I've done that the past when I
got a little backlog I thought that
April after a month is packed with
events and projects as March was that
April would be kind of a winding down
time but that's not actually turning out
to be the case I'm not complaining by
the way because it's great to have lots
of work and have people you know query
me and wanting to hire me for for
various things but there is one there is
one what would we call it at not
attribute but one one commodity that we
never get enough of and there's a finite
supply and it keeps on whittling that is
time alright so we've got to make good
use of my time through time management
and you know I've had to actually start
saying no to quite a few projects that
people are proposing alright events
we've got less events coming up but
they're pretty cool ones um this weekend
i'm going to be out in oak lair
wisconsin at the wisconsin philosophical
association i'm presenting a paper that
i had been
working on for quite some time and
revised a bit it's going to be going out
for publication hopefully this this
summer called what precisely is pro a
racist in Aristotle's works if you know
much about Aristotle's virtue ethics you
know this is a really important term and
so I'm trying to unpack that the 14th
7pm brookfield public library in this
this world's of speculative fiction
series that we're doing throughout the
entire year like i mentioned CS Lewis's
space trilogy so out of the silent
planet that's Mars perelandra that's
that's Venus and that hideous strength
earth great books really really
wonderful writing and we'll be
discussing the philosophical themes that
that lewis built into those a little bit
about the reception of them as well
April sixteenth i'll be doing a workshop
privately along with my wife and he
shocked and my partner in reason i 0 for
a river west radio we're helping them
out we've been consulting with them and
we're going to be doing a workshop to
help their show producers uh you know go
through the process of you know figuring
out how to pitch their show identify
underwriters engage in effective
communication and follow up with them
get over some of the the psychological
hang-up set sometimes come about when
you have to ask people for money which
is what underwriting is all about so
that's that's something that we're doing
it's it's part of our local community
and we're really proud of that April
twentieth at five p.m. central standard
time i'll be doing a half-hour Hagel
public Q&A google hangout and anybody
can go to that that's that's something
that that I provide free of charge in
but it's it's underwritten by my Patrian
subscribers it was one of those things
once I reached a certain level of
supported I said it well you know you
guys want to chip in I'll do something
for everybody else as well
a little paradoxical but I think it's a
good thing now let's talk about the
Aristotle nickimja k an ethics course
because that is a major thing like i
said the class is not beginning as such
in april although i'll give you a little
sneak preview of that in a what we're
going to call an open house that i
haven't scheduled yet and we will be
doing later on this month just to get
people a little taste and you know
answer any questions that they've got
this is not a course that i am teaching
with a plano or the gps or marist or
anybody else this is the first course
that we are offering directly through
reason I oh I'm you know I'm very happy
to work with innovative educational
platforms and organizations but I wanted
to have a bit more you might say
executive control over the content and
the way that the institution works and
so we're keeping it in house this is
going to be the first of many courses
that we are going to be offering for for
the general public not for credit for
personal enrichment and and for you know
increasing your knowledge and engaging
with with great thinkers great texts and
you know an interpreter of them like me
so I pulled my you know various you
might say constituents right people on
Facebook people on Twitter people on
Google+ people who follow my youtube
channel people who subscribe to our
newsletter and Aristotle's Nicomachean
ethics one so that is what we're
starting with we're going to go through
the entire text in six weeks within the
course there's going to be not only you
know videos you guys know me through
videos but a lot of other resources as
well lesson pages handouts links to
relevant material recommended readings
I'll probably create a glossary as well
if I don't find a great one already
there online and it also includes a
weekly interaction
with me the professor who is teaching it
there's two levels of tuition for the
course if you're not interested in
writing papers and getting feedback on
that you can take it for 150 dollars for
a six week course which is pretty good
deal particularly when you compare it to
some of the other stuff that's out there
and if you want you know some much more
engaged in interaction through writing
papers and that sort of thing that it
costs double that three hundred dollars
still a great deal and like I said we're
going to have an open house later on
this this month probably in the last two
weeks of the month we have to figure out
exactly how we're going to host it when
we're going to host it so stay tuned for
that and I will be you know answering
questions about it there but if you have
questions about the course here you
could ask them on this video or you
could wait you know I'm going to shoot
another video where I talk about the
course and you can ask your questions on
that or email me directly at Greg at
reason I up we'll be putting the link
here for enrollment in the course though
now let's talk about what else we've got
going on and you know if you still got
more tutoring and philosophical
counseling and coaching assignments
lined up for this this this month
scheduled I do have slots open if people
are interested in that sort of thing you
want to email me and enquire directly
you can look at these look at reason I a
website and that will show you where it
is still doing some more academic
writing one of the things that is going
to be a little bit of a perk for the
Aristotle course that I think is pretty
cool is I'm you know I've been wanting
to do ebooks for a long time you know
fairly short popular popularly oriented
and inexpensive books that people could
either you know read on a Kindle or
wherever or they want to print on demand
they can do that and so we're going
to work on the first of those this month
and it's going to be on Aristotle and
it's going to be specifically dealing
with the nikah McCain ethics and it's
going to focus on the virtues and vices
that's are going to be one of the the
perks for people taking the course they
get to see the very first version of it
they get to you know say whether they
like it don't like it so that'll be
pretty cool before before we actually
put it out as an e-book you know for the
general public we're going to use it as
not quite a textbook but at least a set
of starting points for for my students
why not let them have something you know
that other people aren't getting access
to they're also going to get to see some
Aristotle videos before anybody else
does as well all right so what else do
we have coming up video work I'm going
to be producing six half hour Hagel
videos actually I'm going to hopefully
shoot some of that footage tonight I'm
going to continue the core concept video
series on Anselm's modal ogion we might
make it through that by the end of the
month and then go into the pro slow gian
which is a bit shorter I'm not going to
shoot as many videos and a very
important work by him the day very taut
a on truth which is a pretty dense also
short work very cool and then we'll see
where we go from from there of course
I'll shoot the video for the talk that
I'm giving on CS Lewis's space trilogy I
won't be recording video for the
Wisconsin philosophical association
presentation but i will do it for the CS
lewis and if i have time people have
been asking me some some interesting
questions and i always like to get to
those and you know give you my take when
I can if I have the time I will try to
shoot some of those videos that would
probably happen closer to the end of the
month than at the beginning of the month
because I still have a lot of work to
dig myself out of I will hopefully be
releasing some new curious courses as
well
all I've got some some material in there
on jean-paul sartre the previous stuff
that i did was mostly on Plato or the
philosophy of religion course but I've
got some sort stuff and then I also want
to do some you know if I can get to it
some Aristotle stuff for that as well
but we'll see you know I might might be
biting off a little bit more than I can
chew especially since I'm going I've
committed myself to writing for stoicism
today I'm going to be continuing a
series on stoicism and anger I'm going
to also be writing in my my other blogs
Rex st anoetic a half-hour Hagel for
those who are interested in that project
or just interested in Hagel to continue
the hey gallant stoicism stuff and then
get into some other topics and if I can
find the time I want to resuscitate that
old blog of mine heavy metal philosopher
then if I have any other time I'm going
to try to write for some other venues
but I won't commit to that because I
don't know if I'll at the time so that's
a pretty busy month ahead and we're
already at the you know the sixth so I
need to really get it get it in gear I
hope all of you have a great month and
if you're interested in the Aristotle
course make sure to check it out because
it's going to be pretty pretty amazing
he's a guy who I've been studying in the
original for how long um well since the
since the early 2000s so any somebody
who I really enjoy you know it's going
to be a great course alright that's
enough about that have a great month and
I will see you in whatever forums we
reconnected